[grunting]
Monsieur Trepagny.
Duquet is gone.
Did you stay on the path?
No.
What sort of a man are you?
I don't know what you mean.
Will you vouch
for Duquet or give
your word on his character?
I take him here
to my [inaudible],,
show him the path to
becoming free, a landed man,
and now he has fled the
contract of his indenture,
leaving me to suspect
what lurks in your heart.
Will you flee or sink
your ax into my skull
the moment I turn my back?
No, sir.
I will let you know if
you abandon our agreement
like our compatriot Duquet, I
will weigh twofold on your hide
the fair and proper
punishment to your ilk.
I'm a man of my word.
You had better be.
Now, tell me of the ram.
It is no coincidence that Duquet
took his leave after bringing
that cursed ram here.
Duquet said nothing to me.
Now I fear I have loosed
something into this world I
will soon regret.
Duquet?
TREPAGNY: Yes.
A cunning creature who, if
he does not find his death,
will prosper as frog
to pond, rat to rot.
The clever Duquet will
find his place in Warwick.
Duquet is afraid of the woods.
He will get lost and die.
I'm sure of it.
He will overcome that
fear because he is a rat,
and he will prosper with
these teeth and claws
and never forebear it.
I will search again tomorrow.
No.
You must return to your duties.
Now, if I may avail myself of
your fire just for a moment.